zu dem thema mallorca und zu der familie
die sich mit corona angesteckt hat aber
vor allem für das viel größere thema was
passiert jetzt mit urlaubsrückkehrern
wir haben gerade schon die aussage von
karl lauterbach gehört möchten jetzt
darüber sprechen mit dem biologen dr
martin stürmer köpfte stürmer karl
lauterbach sagt dass man jetzt alle
rückkehrer testen müsste am besten noch
am flughafen um vor die nächste welle zu
kommen wie schätzen sie es einen wie
groß ist die gefahr die jetzt ausgeht
von all den urlaubsrückkehrer nicht nur
aus mallorca auf mallorca
ja sie haben es genau richtig gesagt ich
finde diese fokussierung auf mallorca
ist etwas irreführend und nicht richtig
man muss entweder ganz konsequent sagen
dass jeder urlauber der egal ob in
deutschland oder im ausland urlaub macht
und zurückkehrt getestet wird oder man
macht das was ich eigentlich für
sinnvoll halte dann konzentriert sich
tatsächlich weiterhin auch die vom lkw
vom work institute ausgewiesenen
risikogebieten und testet die rückkehrer
aus diesen gebieten mallorca ist noch
keins diese vierköpfige familie hat sich
wohl nach dem was man bis jetzt gehört
haben keinem aktiv einem risiko
ausgesetzt indem sie auf partys gewesen
ist und so eine situation kann eben auch
genauso gut in deutschland am
ostseestrand passieren beispielsweise am
frankfurter flughafen kann man sich für
90 euro jetzt direkt auf corona testen
lassen wenn sie es für sinnvoll halten
wenn dass es jetzt an allen deutschen
flughäfen gibt ja das hilft natürlich
das zeitnahe testung erfolgen kann
wie gesagt ob das netz tatsächlich dazu
beiträgt die die wellen zu aufzuhalten
lassen wir mal dahingestellt es wird
sicherlich einige fälle dann frühzeitig
aufklären können
da gebe ich an lauterbach recht aber wir
haben genauso gut das problem wie gesagt
im lande wir müssen uns insgesamt eine
gute test strategie überlegen mit der
wir das risiko minimieren dass wir neue
infektionen aus den urlaubsländern
zurückbekommen